And these are the numbers you get.
Interestingly enough, these both correspond to a difference of exactly 15% from this number.
It's not a coincidence.
It has to do with the fact that d shows up here in the numerator and there's no exponent on d.
Well, there's a little 1 hidden there, but we don't need to write that.
This is getting into some serious error analysis,
which is a really fascinating topic and requires a little bit of calculus to get into,
but in future classes you can learn about this in more detail.
For now, it's enough to know that our 15% error in distance measurement
corresponds to a 15% error in circumference calculation.